guys took you three about whole take 100  calm down now that given mm-hmm  that's right good did we do that again  okay so again let me take that again to  try to do this right this is never pull  up the vision Pacific colors and a  statistic about Batman openness take the  text of the typical housewife which is  like so we're going in on baby shower  weight is up in here flu so Macedonia  there are various constant yet carrot  coconut please  of course to push transcend  [Music]  okay  have some explaining to do Veronica here  she is loja be disappointed they don't  always four times call for desperate but  what tragic methods like that I do like  that slap are you coming or not  [Music]  yeah wait from what dancer ballet dancer  takes your furniture over wine and hit  me again  [Music]  nevermind after that Josh Peck is it so  I'm going to be a public obviously upper  Riverdale  [Music]